نحن نتابع وصول اذا موكبه الرئيس دونالد
ترامب الى برج ترامب بالفعل اذا طبعا
معززا بتعزيزات امنيه كذلك عدسات صحفيين
اذا
مسلطه اذا على المدخل الرئيسي
لبرج ترامب والشارع المؤدي اليه اذا في
نيويورك كما نتابع معكم في هذه الصور
المباشره طبعا
ترامب كان استقل طائرته الخاصه
في رحله دامت حوالي ساعتين ونصف باتجاه
نيويورك هذه الان عدسه العربيه اذا من
زاويه اخرى كذلك ووصول
الموكب موكب رئيس دونالد ترامب من المطار
اذا ووصوله الى برج ترامب او ترامب حيث
سيقيم هذه الليله قبل ان يمثل غدا امام
قاضي محكمه الجنايات في منهات
طبعا اذا هذه هي الصور نحن نتابع اذا
هناك فريق من مساعدي ترامب اذا ينزلون من
سيارات الموكب اذا باتجاه
المدخل الرئيسي
اذا نحن مشاهدينا معكم في هذه التغطيه
الخاصه لوصول الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب الذي سيقف غدا امام قاضي
محكمه الجنايات في منهاتن حيث تفتح امامه
لائحه الاتهامات التي تقول التسريبات
بانها تشمل 34 اتهاما ها هو دونالد ترامب
اذا نتابعه الان وهو يحيي اذا الصحفيين
وطبعا مجموعه من المحتشدين امام المدخل هو
دخل بسرعه اذا لم يتوقف كثيرا دخل اذن
بسرعه ونشاهد كذلك مجموعه من فريقه الامني
ومساعديه كذلك مع رئيس الامريكي السابق
اذا هم يدخلون الى
برج ترامب او ترامب مقر اقامته الذي كان
رئيسيا حيث عاش في هذا المبنى لعقود
وسنوات طويله عندما بنى ثروته كذلك
واعماله كذلك هناك في نيويورك اذن الان
وصل الرئيس دونالد ترامب الى مقر اقامته
في نيويورك قاد ما من فلوريدا